in dem moment wo ich dieses video
aufnehmen er ist 17 uhr 21 18 25 20 ist
es ein samstag und ich sitze seit 12 uhr
also seit über fünf stunden vor meinem
pc durchgehend vom mbc und versuche eine
video de zu finden
und mir fällt keine video idee ein gong
und dann ganz kurz bevor ich gedacht
aber das ist jetzt endgültig durchdrehe
wurde mir auf meiner startseite ein
video vorgeschlagen von dem englischen
youtube alle shops mit dem titel
breakbälle wie die onz spielt darin gta
ins spiel indem man permanent
irgendwelche regeln bricht also ist das
video auch oft vorbei und ich danken
will und das könnte meine lösung für
heute sein ich hatte mich schon weil ich
mir dachte mir fällt wohl wirklich keine
video die leute einfach mit dave
verabredet um die fischer zu machen und
da will ich jetzt hingehen und wir
werden dieses video einfach wenn dave
lacht die chance und was denkt lacht
wenn nicht mit der kamera auf ihn
gerichts darauf hin zu laufen sie die
sind relativ hoch
ich treffe ich mit dave in sechs minuten
um vorwärts loslaufen und dave treffen
sei der vollständigkeit habe noch eine
sache gesagt am luca hat auch sein teil
auch so eine serie gemacht wo er so
videos ganz spontan beendet sollte die
noch nicht gesehen haben dieses video
unterhalten habe ich euch die aufnahme
unten verlinkt beziehungsweise ein video
davon und jetzt
ich würde sogar
die leute selbst noch nicht da ich
dachte das wird ganz easy und ich
einfach zu seinem tischchen und den
anfang machte aber ist noch nicht da
deswegen habe ich mich jetzt mit den
besitzern der shisha bar zusammen getan
man das so machen ich verstecke mich
jetzt drinnen oder draußen setzen wir
jetzt mal raus nimmt und dann sagt sie
mir bescheid dann fühle mich hier wie
die fenster aber so in bessenbach zu
bringen
b
[Musik]